[Music]
so I I'm disrespectful and you're not I
just want to clear anything on that
because you're perfect you're an adult
doesn't mean that gives you the right
thing desperate respect your parents and
you don't think you are rude at all to
me and my husband and his family
you don't think you are rude at all I
don't think I was rude people are
seriously narrow-minded really they
asked me a question and I answered and I
said I didn't want to be rude I don't
mean to offend you but how can you even
live here how can you do that
another thing you really underestimate
me as a person I don't you you said to
them I don't think she's capable of
living here that's not what I said I
heard it not kids
you're wrong shut the [ __ ] up
that's not disrespectful you know that's
not disrespectful I didn't have a room
full of people I'd probably slap you in
the face because you're disrespectful
to your mother now what you literally
got to talk to anyone else like that you
don't think I'm not capable of living
I'm here for you you also say capable
you also said that I don't have a
backbone you basically think I'm a
doormat you underestimate me then you
get what I think so when your husband
leaves you on Saturdays and Sundays with
two babies because he wants to go
fishing and you complain about that I do
everything in the house I do everything
and then he leaves how should I feel
okay mom okay and you're so perfect you
literally get tell me it was perfect
just get it tell me I'm disrespectful
talk about a hypocrite enjoy your trip
that was insane
[Music]